is your four-year-old gender-fluid well
now you can send him or her or Zim Orser
to transgender summer camp for kids in
where else the San Francisco Bay Area
plus we'll have roaming millennial
Amanda presto Giacomo and Jacob Airy
during the panel of deplorable z-- to
discuss speaking of the youths social
media depression among kids president
Trump's tough talk on North Korea and
the urgent need for the government to
regulate sex robots
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
later too because we're going to have a
final thought that is identifying as
stuff I like because today is book
lovers day so I'll be giving out some
book reviews as a best-selling non
writing author I think it's my place to
tell you all what you should be reading
for the next over the rest of the summer
rather so we have to talk about rainbow
day camp
it is a camp in the San Francisco Bay
Area for transgender toddlers the ages
of the people who go are four to twelve
the parents of the people who go are
obviously abusive and very confused
so this camp is not new this game has
been around for three years it just made
big headlines recently because the
enrollment has increased by three times
just this year so obviously
transgenderism is in the air we're
talking about it all the time in the
culture and apparently this has been
good business for transgender youth camp
one of the directors said it has been a
sea change maybe we can even call it a
tsunami in the number of little kids
showing up with their families and so
when their kids show up even when
they're four years old they are asked
when they register which pronoun they
would prefer to be called by and it's
either she or he or Z or whatever and
for the record Marshall I would only
like to be referred to with the pronouns
sir sir or master in the accusative
certainement well make a note and we'll
talk about it later
luckily we have obtained a letter from
one of the attendees of this camp we
have access to great stuff at this show
we have obtained a letter can we play it
not a holiday
oh I hate Ramada don't leave me out in
the forest where I might get eaten by a
bear take me home I promise I will not
make noise so trans camp is apparently
like band camp you know it's just like
any it's much more socially isolating
obviously and confusing but it's just
like any other camp you go to basketball
camp you go to baseball camp whatever
there it is a little interesting in that
most summer camps that we think of our
camps to do something so I had to go to
basketball camp when I was a kid one
time it turned out about as you would
expect I think but this is a camp about
who you are imagining yourself to be who
you deeply think yourself to be and
obviously adolescence is a very
confusing time we take on a lot of
different identities that we try out no
joke when I was when I was four years
old I did identify as Batman for about a
month I had people call me Batman
seriously and that's just a very
imaginative time these parents are
obviously taking it to be some deep
profound immutable fact of their child's
existence and sending this to their camp
it can't possibly be good but you know
even the founder of this camp sander
Collins admits quote a decade ago the
camp wouldn't have existed
eventually I do believe it won't be so
innovative she's probably right she said
I didn't know you could be transgender
at a very young age but my daughter knew
for sure at - I don't know if that's
exactly right what could go wrong with
allowing your two-year-old to deny the
facts of their biology into Denali
reality to their parents well there are
a lot of scientific data on this that I
think the mainstream media are ignoring
and I'm sorry if I know these scientific
data are that that is called hate speech
if you're at Google or we work for the
mainstream journalists outlets but we
know there are high rates of post-op
regret people who transition from one
gender to another they undergo surgery
to look more like the the other sex and
they regret it later some of these
studies put the number at 20% so one in
five people who undergo this process and
the surge
is according to some studies regret it
ultimately go back or they are just
upset that they made that decision most
children who identify as transsexual or
as the other sex the vast majority of
those kids will change their mind by the
time they become adults they go on to
lead perfectly normal lives as a one
study put the numbers high to eighty
percent eighty percent of kids who
identify they're a boy but they think
they're a girl will change their mind by
the time they pass through puberty and
enter into adulthood now there was a
review of more than 100 international
medical studies so this is a
meta-analysis of all these studies that
found quote no robust scientific
evidence the gender reassignment surgery
is clinically effective and this is why
Paul McHugh who was a pioneer of this
surgery at Johns Hopkins he was chair of
psychology at Johns Hopkins he stopped
doing the surgery because quote there's
little scientific evidence for the
therapeutic value of interventions that
delay puberty or modify the secondary
sex characteristics of adolescents there
is no evidence that all children who
express gender atypical thoughts or
behavior should be encouraged to become
transgender and that's what you know
trans is in the news all the time you
can't escape it for some reason an issue
that effects a vanishingly small
percentage of the population is all
anybody wants to talk about anymore
especially on the left but what is
really worth talking about here is that
we're talking about kids so if you put a
kid on this road you tell a
four-year-old boy that he's really a
girl that's going to lead to a lot of
confusion but if you tell a prepubescent
kid that that you indulge in these
delusions and that the boy is really a
girl and you suppress their puberty
hormones you're mutilating them for life
I mean that damage is not easily undone
if it's possible to fix it at all and
you know there are people who have gone
through this when they were children who
have come to regret it we have their
testimonies they talk about it here is
one example hi my name is Carrie and my
22 year old D transition woman I was a
pediatric transition ER so I started
medical transition when I was underage
and I stopped transitioning nearly a
year ago and for me he transition
involved you know a lot of thought and a
lot of unlearning of what I understood
about myself when I was transitioning I
felt a lot of intent the very intense
body dysphoria that felt very innate and
very integral at the time to to the way
I perceived myself in the world and when
I came to realize eventually was that
this was not the case that there were
all these factors that played into my
dysphoria dissociation and feelings of
inferiority for being female and
depression and body dysmorphia you know
all of these things contributing to this
kind of general sense of alienation
sense of otherness from-from the people
around me and specifically from other
women and there are there are these
conditions that go along with gender
dysphoria there is a 2 to 3 times
increase in likelihood if you're if you
have gender dysphoria that you'll suffer
from some other mental affliction
including anxiety or depression or so on
and so forth obviously we know that the
suicide rates according to most studies
are identical pre and post-op and the
left and people who support the
transgender transgenderism movement
would say well that's social stress the
kids are bullied at school if we just
stop bullying them those rates go away
there's there's very little evidence of
this there's that might be a factor but
there's no reason to believe that that's
the main factor or or the you know the
sole factor when it comes to all of
these other conditions that accompany
gender dysphoria let's look like Cara
keep going on so when I was
transitioning every every step of
transition really really felt like this
huge hi of relief from this foria but
sooner or later you know they would come
back in another form so you know once I
was on testosterone I I wanted to change
my name and once they take my name I
wanted a mastectomy once I had a
mastectomy I wanted a hysterectomy a lot
of surgeries so on and so forth this is
a really common topic in trance circles
you know shifting dysphoria and at some
point I realized that that wasn't going
to stop transition didn't really make my
dysphoria better it
just kind of kept moving the goalposts
so moving the goalposts is exactly the
point the issue here is that carry this
girl was treating the symptoms of her
psychological condition she wasn't
treating the root cause of it if there
is a even as a way to treat the root
cause of it and so it just kept moving
the more she transitioned the more she
did the more she had to do the more she
felt that she had to do and carry
started transitioning going through this
process at 17 she was underage it meant
now you know how crazy 17 year olds are
you not crazy you were at 17 have
different you were at 17 in your as an
adult oh my god exactly
well this kid marshals exactly the same
marshal hasn't matured physically or
emotionally since he was seven but for
most people they do change over time and
imagine if she wasn't seventeen imagine
she were seven imagine if she were four
years old which is what's going on at
this camp in San Francisco cannot be
good there's another example of not just
people who went through this as kids but
also people who went through the
transition and changed their their
gender when they were adults regretting
it not long after and here's an example
he he's pretty prominent he's talked
about this in written books about it
Walt hire who went through the surgery
and experienced regret years later do we
have them here with us now by Skype is
speaker and author of several books
addressing sex change regret Walt hire
Walt thanks for joining us today
yeah thanks for having me on first of
all not only have you done extensive
research on sex change surgery you've
been through the process yourself but
you say it fix nothing what can you
share with us about that yeah you know
when people go through this gender
change there's very high expectations
that you know their life is just going
to be wonderful and everything's going
to be great now I can tell you the way
it starts that was true for me but then
there's a time what I call when you kind
of begin to sober up and realize that
gender reassignment surgery really
doesn't make you a female it's much more
to being a woman than just having some
cosmetic surgery and hormones so it
didn't fix the problem for Walt he
and he lived for eight years as a woman
appearing to be a woman and wearing
women's clothing but it didn't it didn't
fix the problem and this surgery that
he's now reversed or tried to fix by
other surgical means has really damaged
his life he talks openly about that and
he was encouraged by others to do it and
that's what we're seeing a lot in the
culture now Bruce Jenner was encouraged
by a lot of people to transform into
Caitlyn Jenner these kids are being
encouraged by their parents at age four
to indulge in this delusion and it is it
pulls on the heartstrings a little bit
because it's a real affliction and also
because men and women don't look that
different especially like someone like
Marshall you know I mean if you put Noor
Marshall next to a woman it would be
very good well I'll use another example
if I put on these glasses
I am indistinguishable from Rachel
Maddow but and so obviously men and
women are the same species they share a
lot of physical traits just just ask
Google about that but the the
psychological problems and and therefore
the philosophical problems they come up
with it are a little clear when you look
at other forms of body dysmorphia and
delusion here there is an extreme
example a guy whose name is stalking cat
Dennis Abner do we have it that is never
considered self human in tennis his eyes
his transformation is only a formality
everything I see and do I relate to as a
cat I'm told i purr in my sleep so but
there's this guy a stalking cat he he is
a man who I think was in the Navy and
then he decided to get $200,000 worth of
surgery to tattoo his face pull up his
cheeks have whiskers sticking out cut
off parts of his ears and all so that he
could appear more like a cat because he
was under the impression that he really
deep down inside somewhere is a cat
he has cat-like abilities and
what-have-you and it is a funny story
obviously it is out there it looks kind
of ridiculous but it's really sad
because this is a real human being and
the we can see much more clearly what
happens when we indulge delusion when
it's not just a boy becoming like a girl
when boys and girls can look like each
other but when it's a boy
trying to look like an animal or
something to that effect that this is
ultimately I think what brings up the
central flaw in the left's embrace of
transgenders in the central
contradiction which is that the left on
the one hand says men and women are
exactly the same
they're indiscernible that just talked
to Google fired a guy for contradicting
this yesterday men can do everything the
women can do and vice versa there are no
categorical differences on the other
hand they're saying that the sexes are
so totally different that if you feel
that you are a certain way
metaphysically or you really want to be
a different way metaphysically you
should undergo costly painful and
extensive surgery just to have the
cosmetic appearance of looking like that
other six they've never been able to
resolve this conflict and I think that's
why I think it has shown one of the
major paradoxes at the heart of leftist
intersectional hierarchies but now that
we've talked about the transgender camp
now that we've talked about leftist
hierarchies we have to get to the
exciting part of the show our panel of
deplorable z-- we have with us again
roaming millennial you know her from all
the youtubes The Daily wires favorite
Amanda presto Giacomo and for some
reason Jacob areas back roaming are we
being unfair here these children can
suffer intensely they get bullied why
shouldn't we ship them off to
transgender camp well I think you know
to answer the first question that you
posed at the beginning of the show is
your child gender fluid regardless of
how you feel about the transgender issue
I think we could all agree that nobody
is gender fluid look at all just not a
real thing I always try not to talk
about gender fluids I find it very
impolite but I agree with you probably
that's right and you know what I
mentioned this the last time as all with
you guys but when it comes to children I
think trying to impose these sort of
gender ideologies it is child abuse and
you know a lot of people say no you know
it's just thing we've always benched for
the kids this isn't you know a sort of
indoctrination they're actually they're
one of documented instances any time you
hear about these you know these
transgendered child children activism
eat or not you know what I mean a lot of
them are added up selves trans or have
been trans activists before there
report and you got to think to yourself
okay wait only a fraction of a percent
of people in the general population is
actually trans what is the likelihood of
a trans person or someone who is already
a trans activist then having a trans
child is like no I think there's
definitely a case where as a parent
these people are inflicting their
ideologies and their their views on
gender on to their children and it's
something that I think a lot of children
are going to have issues dealing with as
they curl up it has become very
ideological I mean that is why yeah just
as you said there are not a lot of these
people in the world if there are a
handful of these people around and yet
it's all we hear about it's all we're
talking about there TV shows about it
it's always in the news but there
doesn't appear to be a cure so Amanda if
there isn't a cure for this at the
moment if there's really doesn't seem to
be an effective way to reduce suicide
rates or depression surgically then why
shouldn't we just tell these people to
call themselves whatever name they want
and pretend to be whatever sex they want
yeah I mean it's particularly we
shouldn't and it's because you know this
is really tied to depression this is a
psychological disorder so like
mutilating your body and it's like
getting a knee surgery when you pop out
your shoulders not not addressing the
issue at all we should not be
encouraging this especially me
particularly with children who as you
said grow out of this confusion I mean
we're just basically indoctrinating you
know Tommy the two-year-old associated I
know sore on Wednesday and then on
Thursday he's a girl yeah and you
carrying yourself right you'd actually
parent your child and you know I think I
mean eighty percent of these kids that's
a left alone number grow out you know of
these studies grew out of this confusion
we should not be pushing this on them I
mean kids are being utilized there
oughta victims of this it's it's really
vile stuff and anyone who speaks out
against it this is the worst part you're
labeled as transphobic that you hate you
know people suffer from this mental
disorder no I mean there's actual real
damage to this and this is a political
movement you know they hate the nuclear
family they hate you know they kind of
are contradicting feminism because they
want sameness but then all of a sudden
you know men and women are so different
you can transition it's just
it's a hot mess and it's a really nasty
political movement that is hurting
people and creating on a victim's
stunning bigotry from Amanda press to
Giacomo but that is unreal you both
bring up this interesting point which is
that it's child abuse
it looks like child abuse it is parents
mutilating their children before now but
not only before they can consent but
before they go through puberty and
they're making a decision that will
impact the rest of their lives
Jacob we conservatives are very
skeptical of government interference
should the government step in here
should the government come in and stop
parents from encouraging this in their
children I think it depends on the
situation and in some cases where the
parent is just like oh you think you're
a girl go along with it but maybe in the
circumstances whereas Amanda points out
that they're actually causing physical
harm to their kids
then then yes I think that is where the
government needs to step in is like hey
is your child actually feeling this way
or is this just a phase they're going
through I had a friend who was a skater
girl she she wore t-shirts and blue
jeans and skateboard all the time but
she was about as girly girl as you could
get could you imagine if she had these
trans activist parents like oh my gosh
you must be a boy as you imagine what
that would have done to her but it's
instead they just let her go and she
grew out of her skateboarding phase what
I would literally like a boy growing up
like my dad was a wrestling castleball
so much like I went all the practices
like if I wasn't being born like you
know five years ago they would have told
me I was a boy like it's exciting I mean
it one of the signs of a tomboy is that
not allowed it's like gender stereotypes
are amplified on the left people who
condemn them it doesn't make any sense
yeah it's mind-blowing that's true too
like at one one point gender is nothing
but also gender is everything like at
one point gender is a social contract
but it's also something biologically
that we are and we can tell through our
different brains like you have to pick
one I mean you could go for either one
but just be consistent that's right I
also have a very hard time believing
amanda was ever a tomboy but I will take
your word for it okay we need to move on
now we need to get to the news which
means that all of you dirty cheapskates
who don't
for the daily wire you don't get to hear
the rest you don't get to see the panel
you don't get to engage with us on the
news unless you go to daily wire comm
and pay $10 per month $100 a year and
you will get also the leftist here's
tumblr keeps your leftist tears hot or
cold always salty and delicious not only
do you get my show and the wonderful
panel of deplorable but you get the Ben
Shapiro show which is I think right now
the number two highest ranked podcast in
the country what number are we Michael I
well we're a number ten news and
politics I think 10 or 11 but Ben is one
spot behind Oprah so you've got to go
help and push him over and you get the
Andrew Klavan show which is also ranked
very high I think all three of the shows
are ranked in the top 25 so it what a
deal what did $10 a month unbelievable
go to daily wire calm right now
subscribe we'll be right back
now we have important news to get to
president Trump warned yesterday quote I
love him so much
he warned North Korea best not make any
more threats to the United States they
will be met with fire and fury like the
world has never seen this may be the
greatest international threat since the
Gipper I just want to pull this others
my favorite one do we have it
my fellow Americans I'm pleased to tell
you today that I've signed legislation
that will outlaw Russia forever we've
been bombing in five minutes almost as
good as the Gipper himself he was
kidding Ronald Reagan was or was he he
did outlaw Russia forever roaming was
Trump's threat reckless and rash or was
it pitch perfect and very enjoyable well
something that I I think it's great that
you included was the fact that he
prefaced that phrase with a you know if
you in North Korea could use to make
threats against the United States right
because I feel like a lot of the
reporting about this quote has a
forgotten to mention that conveniently
and sort of try to paint Trump as the
aggressor in the situation and look I'm
not sure I would ever use phrases like
you know fire and power just from a I
don't know hyperbolic this is real life
not over the rings I'm approached I'm
not convinced it is any nerve but sure
go ahead I think if there's ever a time
to have a strong hand when it comes to
international relations North Korea and
the possibility of you know nuclear
escalation is one of them and I think
that people who are trying to paint this
as a necessary instance of aggression
from prompt they're they're like like I
said not looking at the entire quote in
context and they're also not realizing
just how bad things have gotten over the
past eight years and look you know
regardless of how you think Trump is
handling this at the moment you can't
you definitely can't say that he's the
one who created a situation right just
this ongoing hostility between North
Korea the United States itself that's
been happening for a long time since
Clinton absolutely yeah Bill Clinton
ignored it George W Bush was otherwise
occupied Barack Obama obviously did
nothing about it I think Ben Rhodes was
he tweeted at something the other day to
the effect of you know this all started
before us even though we had time to fix
it
because no one in the Abama
administration can take responsibility
for any single thing at all now Romo
here over there in Asia and Amanda you
are up in Canada New York safely
ensconced in the woods but we are in LA
thank you
yeah what what is going to happen are we
about to be incinerated what's the
threat level from them actually shooting
some missiles over um while I'm in New
York so I can't ask you know but you're
in you're in Canada New York you're up
in like you know you're uh still oh okay
I get it I get it elegant land they
can't all be winners folks you know but
um no I don't think I don't think we're
any so couple things like I don't I
don't think Trump's rhetoric or anything
like that is put at that you know
heightened danger or anything like that
I think that Kim little Kim is is crazy
yes but he's not stupid and he knows
that he will be you know annihilate I
think I think people who study this have
the consensus that basically she just
doesn't want regime change and he's
flexing his muscle he knows that he will
be annihilated if he does something I
think that's kind of the consensus
around us but at the same time we don't
want him to keep making advances so we
need to find a way to make this China's
problem because you know they don't want
refugees coming in there I mean they
have they do some sake enough so I think
Trump saying that he's going to continue
work with China to you know kind of stop
their funding and not let them keep
advancing their you know their nuke and
then you know we can we can just kind of
handle that and fill them but I don't
think the danger is heightened I think
that I think they kind of know that they
will get annihilated by America and her
allies I have to disagree with your
analysis not in the take of the threat
level but in your pronunciation of China
it is a hardship China
Jacob why hasn't Dennis Rodman
straighten this out yet hmm well because
he was an overrated basketball player
and he's an overrated ambassador but in
all seriousness I am on but in all
seriousness I actually I actually think
that President Trump was totally
appropriate
appropriate and fire and fury because
not moments I think hours before even
Ken Jeong specifically said we're going
to bomb I believe it was Guam so yes
yeah of course
I if I was president I would absolutely
say hey we are going to meet this with
fire fury and power and also you know
what if President Obama or Hillary
Clinton was still Hillary Clinton god
forbid was president what would she say
oh that naughty little Kim I mean you
know what is she going to do she gonna
you know her she's going to pursue a
career in in ministry obviously you know
this is not a foreign policy right yes I
think those rhymes wawas after it was
after okay yeah okay baby
there's like a lot flow story that said
that they were like you know they had a
warhead akka miniature warhead or
whatever and then they were making
stress could be sanctioned them and then
Trump made those comments and then I
said we were going to attack wow man I
never they won't
of course they won't because he's a
coward I mean like it's just like that
he's just going to pledge this know what
you'll get annihilate it
yeah absolutely my main takeaway from
this whole discussion is the phrase a
little Kim Roman oil well I just in any
case it's not as if you know Kim Jungman
administration with a rational actor
before this right I me they're actually
in North Korean state-run propaganda
pieces of I don't know if you guys have
seen this but the piece or the little
kid is dreaming of a news being sent
over to the US right I mean this is one
country that is obviously an aggressor
absolutely well that makes me unhappy
you know what else might be making
people unhappy smartphones the Atlantic
just ran a feature article titled have
smartphones destroyed a generation quote
more comfortable online than out
partying post Millennials are safer
physically than adolescents have ever
been but they're on the brink of a
mental health crisis they don't go out
they don't go on dates they stay in the
house my question why would a
thirteen-year-old go on dates when he
can interact with roaming millennial on
YouTube from the comfort of his own
smartphone is intro me is interacting
behind a digital wall so different from
interacting in person well you know this
is something that I I feel complete to
talking about because you know on the
one hand
I love ragging on Millennials as much as
anyone right they're awful but on the
other hand I'm also this massive
introvert who loves the fact that you
can kind of be interacted with people
and be social online while at the same
time you know being at home not wearing
any pen it's an amazing mix we're
roaming millennial now wearing any pain
you heard it on the Michael show this is
by the way I remember 10 all these kind
of cheap tricks like that sorry to
interrupt go ahead well that what my
camera is always from like but you know
I think I think it's the fact that you
know not only are we seeing an increase
in technological advances but we're also
seeing sort of I feel a more hands-off
approach to parenting that we haven't
seen before
so I wouldn't necessarily say that this
is technology technology's fault I just
think it's the fact that you know when I
was younger I used to get kicked out of
the house and get told to play outside I
could have still been playing you know
well at home on TV right I mean the fact
that outside is still there I think is
like being ignored by a lot of parents
who are probably also on their own
smartphones and a tronic device fairness
that's true there's a lot of candy crush
to play jacob is it just promotionally
old people who don't understand the
youths or is there a real threat of
social isolation here I think it's a
mixture of both and we have to be very
careful about how we categorize this
because there are just truly introverted
people who prefer interaction online and
there's absolutely nothing wrong with
that but again we also need to monitor
how that is done because we want I mean
by we I mean whoever parents siblings
guardians they need to be modern these
kids like okay this person really an
introvert or are they getting are they
getting trapped into this big web do
they only identify as an introvert yeah
exactly
because you know there are there are
predators online who take advantage of
some of these people who have social
anxieties I want to know a lot about
this Jacob well you know what can I say
you know I read the I read the
mainstream media this is what they're
telling me but you know we do have to we
do have to be careful that about this
because there I believe that there's a
game going around called the blue whale
challenge where they manipulate people
with social anxiety who are online and
then they ask them to commit suicide and
it's a growing problem in Europe and
it's even reached the United State
so yes parents guardians should
definitely be monitoring their kids
online activity that I'd read about that
about these Russian girls who were
killing themselves because of some
lunatic that they just arrested that now
that's not good Amanda should we be
blaming the social media here is it the
social media that causes the isolation
or is that just an instrument like a
telephone or you know a two cans and a
string is it just a medium and an
instrument or is it really the cause of
the problem I mean I think with any
technology you're going to have pros and
cons and I mean it is a lot to do with
parenting as roaming and and Jacob we're
talking about I mean if you've got a
list any social interaction basis
interaction is valuable I mean we have a
lot of kids don't have these skills just
on that level and then also I mean if
you look at that Atlantic piece even
just with Millennials in the generation
you know right after us it's a huge
discrepancy and with depression based on
just the screen time I mean it does
really affect these kids you know I get
to present in more screen time I have
with Jacob Airy the more depressed I
guess I should write a study about it
sorry go ahead yes but I mean like even
I mean even as a millennial like I'm
really addicted to you know being on for
my job of course but I'm always on
social media and you can kind of get no
suppressed you can get you know caught
up in that and not interact with with
people and that's that's not that's not
helpful so we have to just learn how to
use these things in moderation parents
need to really be aware of this sign
your kids up for sports just dance
whatever like they need to actually
interact it's just it's not it's not
healthy doesn't teach them any skills
that are actually valuable for future
employment and things like that so yeah
sign them up for a sport or buy them a
sex robot there is this prehistoric
story there is a professor at GW law who
insists that the time has come for the
government to regulate that gigantic
problem sex robots now if you're
unfamiliar I think a lot of people are
probably unfamiliar with sex robots we
have a clip from one of the factories
you can't resist that mr. powers Oh
contraire baby I think you can't resist
me hi well maybe that should be
regulated that's a pretty good case
maybe should regulate them Amanda what
are so dangerous about sex robots other
than the guns that are shooting out of
their bosom yeah I mean it's really sad
that we're at this point like this going
to be kind of ties into technology too
and how we're so isolated that we're
going to you know people are delaying
Mayer marriage they're not getting
married so we need sex robots now it's
really sad but the whole regulation
argument was really interesting to me so
that we could you could possibly rape a
robot and like yeah I'm right a lot of
fun it was a great hobby just because
they're not winning now doesn't mean
they're saying yes robot consent like if
that's the case like I'm not going to
you know be profane here but it since
there are a lot of rape going on insect
toy industry like it's I don't
understand their well you know a
four-year-old kid can consent to
radically changing his body forever but
at all can't consent to sex can't you
just read a blog every once in a while
oh man yeah Wow professor was trying to
give right to a robot I'm liking me
focus on maybe rights of the unborn
first and then capital robots make it so
bigoted you are rubbing there it is a
legitimate question here I mean you
could have I don't know if you can rape
a robot but you could make a sex doll
that looks like a little kid or we're
like a rape victim or something is there
is there any legitimate reason to
regulate this industry similar to say
child pornography or something like that
or are we just talking about absolutely
nothing well I think there like when you
mentioned anything to do with children I
think there definitely is a reason for
this to be regulated I know I've heard
the argument be made that like child
dolls might be helpful as a way of sort
of releasing any urges that actually
bring a real challenge to it but I think
if you are someone who's suffering from
that affliction therapy is what you need
not in context also definitely yes yeah
when it comes to I know which is more
every day right that's I reserve oh yeah
Holocaust issue regulate it good blah
you know on a larger scale I think the
whole idea of regulating sex robots it
kind of begs the question like what
exactly qualifies as a sex robot versus
just you know our run-of-the-mill
sex toy that has mechanical operations I
can't believe I'm talking to you more
run-of-the-mill robot fighting on taters
you know I mean yeah I mean Roomba with
like some I don't know alluring eyes
painted on right like where would they
draw the line if you're a beating heart
I'm not throat sex robot I'm just you
know anti-government intervention of the
half subside with that in this case fair
enough Jacob the essential question here
though is why would anyone want to have
sex with a robot when there are people
you can all you can also it's not just
robot you can also have sex of people
what what is what is the basis for the
why are people trending toward this I
think it's it's a way of just
disconnecting from reality
so everyone goes in because of left-wing
propaganda you're told oh you can have
this you can have that and there won't
be any consequences and then they go out
into the real world and say oh man there
are real consequences so then they turn
to robots which are complete frauds and
so I think that's what it has to do with
it it's just a way to escape from
real-world consequences when you make a
mistake or when you do or when you find
out that life is tougher then you're
then you're lesbians dance therapy
professor tells you it is that's
interesting there's also no there's no
social skills nobody has any social
skills like I even go on a date they
can't even hit on a girl like so in the
sense that robots or the next thing
because you know this is this message
with all the new technology tip people
are so isolated and secluded
it's a septa that's a good point and
interesting how so many of these sex
robot things are coming out of Japan
culture that is well not admitted for
the fact that you're people fewer and
fewer people are getting married
going on days I definitely think there's
an element you know I mean no just me
here but there is an element of people
not being able to interact with each
other like we used to be and there was a
study that came out of Japan a little
while ago that a number of teenage boys
would prefer to look at pornography than
to have sex with a woman they actually
preferred sitting in their rooms alone
how crazy oh my gosh it does play into
that this culture act to put a great man
said it does play into this culture of
objectification though it does play into
this materialist culture where believe
it or not there are spiritual and
emotional aspects to sex it's not just
all playing with a doll or something but
for a materialist culture the
materialist generation maybe the
physical is all that is being considered
well into the ironing here is one of the
biggest criticisms of a homeschooling is
the children don't get interaction right
well in public schools they get plenty
of interaction and they're buying sex
robots so you know I don't know I think
that's just kind of a ridiculous a
narrative you know how about that
all right on action in sex robots I have
to say goodbye to you get out of here
because we have a trans final thought
that we need to talk about now do we
have the do we have the trans final
thought of montage this is a final
thought but it's because it's book
lovers day and we're going to turn it
into a sort of stuff I like I'll tell
you about the books that I've been
reading over the last couple years and I
highly recommend them the first one is
poetic diction by Owen Barfield he was
an inkling friend of CS Lewis and all of
those other guys he it's a great book
it's a theory of knowledge and a theory
of language this was recommended to me
by Andrew flavin who actually reads
books I read like two books a decade and
he's read all of the books so we've been
evangelical about recommending this book
to people it's really good I think
especially conservatives and people who
prefer traditional culture and have an
interest in history and philosophy would
really like it so run out there and get
poetic diction the next book I have to
recommend is of course speaking of
Andrew Clavin
the great good thing a secular Jew comes
to faith in Christ I read this book
right when it came out I got an advance
copy of it it's an amazing story of
Andrew Klein
even's conversion from a secular
intellectual Jew in New York to a
Christian and and he talks about his
politics as well and the literature that
brought him along that journey it's
really a profound book
I myself am a revert to Christianity I
it was very edifying to read that and
then when you go to the beach this book
we got to give a little love to ben
shapiro you all know that ben can type
about 120 words per minute he also as
you know speaks about 190 words per
minute and this book flies by it is such
a page-turner true allegiance it is a
fever dream of armageddon from a
conservative standpoint it's really
entertaining it's terrific so when
you're on the beach i recommend reading
that i promise you you won't be able to
read it as fast as been typed it and
speaking of typing books really fast the
final recommendation i have to make a
little self-serving the reasons to vote
for democrats a comprehensive guide the
most exhaustive democratic party
apologize out i it's really good i can
even the president endorsed it he said
it's a great book for your reading
enjoyment even Ben Shapiro endorsed it
he called it thorough I really think as
you gear up for the school year as you
gear up for the fall you want to edify
yourself you want to learn more about
our political systems and American
history and American political
philosophy
go out there you also have to get
reasons to vote for Democrats happy book
lovers day I'm glad that we had this
lovely trans final thought segment I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael no
Leo come back tomorrow we'll do it again
[Music]